i didn't believe in vacations
uh didn't believe in weekends uh you
know
i was focused on software day and night
i want to be able to think about the
future
and feel good about that
when i decided i was going to go do this
crazy thing
i went and told my boss and he said
well hmm let's go for a walk want to be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how billionaires
think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one focus with bill gates
in my 20s and 30s i was fanatical about
software
you know i didn't believe in vacations
i didn't believe in weekends you know
i was focused on software day and night
you know i knew
everybody's license plate i knew when
they came into the parking lot when they
left
uh and i knew
every line of code and it you know i
enjoyed being a fanatic
and you know i was really focused on
microsoft
doing great software and you know
learning from our mistakes and hiring
the best
the best people rule number two be
driven with elon musk
what drives you what what is it that
when you wake up in the morning
do you see a problem and you want to
solve it
i think the thing that drives me is that
i want to be able to think about the
future and
feel good about that so
that you know we're doing what we can to
have the future be be as good as
possible
to be inspired by what is likely to
happen
um and to look forward to
the next day so
that's that's what really really drives
me is is trying to figure out
uh how do we how to make sure that
things are great and
and going to be so and
that's the underlying principle behind
tesla and spacex
is that um i think it's it's pretty
important that we accelerate the
transition to
uh sustainable generation and
consumption of energy
um it's it's inevitable but it's it
matters if we have if it happens sooner
or
later um and then spacex is about
um helping make life multi-planetary
and doing what we can to continue the
the dream of apollo
and ultimately make contribution
to life becoming multi-planetary rule
number three
minimize your regrets with jeff bezos
from the very beginning
um in 1994 when i came across this fact
that the web was growing at 2300 a year
i was working on wall street very
specialized kind of investment bank
called a quantitative hedge fund a
company called d e shaw
and uh i uh when i
decided i was going to go do this crazy
thing i went and told my boss
and he said well let's go for a walk so
we went on a two-hour walk in central
park and
he actually thought it was a good idea
he's a very smart guy his name is david
shaw he's one of the few people i know
who has a fully developed left brain a
photovoltaic brain just a super smart
guy
and he said this is a great idea but it
would be a better idea for somebody
who didn't already have a good job
and um
and uh that was actually a compelling
argument to me
and so i went away he convinced me to
think about it for two more days
and it was very hard to make that
decision
and until i found the right framework in
which to make the decision
i think because i know there are a lot
of people who are interested in
entrepreneurial activities out there
i think this could be useful it's
it's that it's the right framework for
me anyway to make the kind of decision
was a regret minimization framework
so i projected myself into the future
and i'm 80 years old and i'm looking
back on my life
what do i want to have done at that
point i want to minimize all the regrets
that i have
and i knew that when i was 80 there was
no chance that i would
regret having walked away from my 1994
wall street bonus or any of that kind of
thing i wouldn't even remember that
but i did think there was a chance that
i might regret not having participated
somehow and this thing that i thought
was going to be very exciting called the
internet
and and i also knew that if i tried and
failed
i wouldn't regret that so once i thought
about it that way it become
became incredibly easy to make that
decision rule number four
achieve your potential with grant
cardone just this depression thing
like this this is a topic that interests
me so much have you ever dealt with it
at all
totally okay almost my whole life still
a little bit
uh no well what happens is socially we
say it's depression
but what if okay what if
it wasn't depression and it was just
truth
that i'm having to sleep with my own
truth that i can do more
right so why wouldn't i be a bit
depressed
if i have this potential and i'm
operating here
every individual knows what they're
capable of right so
if i know i have this much potential
and i'm living here wouldn't i be
like a little bit disappointed with
myself
now where did where what happened where
because back in the 50s
there was no depression nobody was
talking about depression people were
talking about
how do i get to the next level right
today in our in our
psychiatric community where where drugs
are where the average
american has eight prescriptions sitting
in their medicine cabinet
like i'm on one drug i got to take a
second drug
to handle the third drug because of the
blood pressure drug because of this drug
and dude i'm stacking out like why
because i was depressed why am i
depressed because i don't look like
i don't have his arms i have the
potential to have his arms
maybe not pretty close but but but it
would require me to go to work
right or or i need to look a different
way or i'm i'm aging or
whatever the deal is right like so for
me i have always struggled with
depression
but it was more because people were
telling me i was depressed when the
truth is i was just disappointed man
me too i was disappointed with me me too
you know my mom my mom would always tell
me my mom was always the first person i
would call
any time i scored and she was my best
friend
and and she passed when when about nine
years ago when sabrina was born five
days later sabrina was born
and um every score i had i was 51 years
old man
between 25 and 51 every score i had my
mom was the first person i called
mom i did this every time she had the
same response
son that's great but i love you just the
way you are
over and over she told me that and then
one day i'm like
but i don't now i can't really say that
a whole bunch of people are gonna say
why don't you love you just the way you
are something wrong with you
because there's that whole culture out
there this this uh i don't know what the
term
is but it's a um this this this holistic
idea that you should love yourself the
way you are i would tell
everybody dude if you know that you can
do more
do not love who you are achieve who you
can be
because you can be more he's done it
i've done it and and i did it by by
by replacing the depression concept not
doing the drugs by the way i was put on
them like five or six times and threw
him away and just said you know what i'm
gonna go for my goals i'm gonna go for
the thing
my potential if i'm gonna screw this up
i'm gonna i'm gonna screw it up grant's
way
not that way hey man how you doing buddy
good how are you
you got a book coming out don't you uh
you just came out
where can people get it get it on amazon
easiest spot
built to serve right there let's go man
if you guys don't know evan follow evan
carmichael
he's got a new book out build a server
go grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five stand out from the crowd
with sarah blakely
the packaging what am i going to do for
the packaging i knew i
thought as a consumer i didn't know
anything else i'd never actually taken a
marketing class either in my life
but i knew as a consumer i was
frustrated i was going into the hosiery
departments and everything looked the
same
it was the same beige package or the
same white package with the same half
naked woman that been on there for 30
years
and i couldn't tell what i was buying so
i said to myself
i'm going to do this different i want it
to be my favorite color red
no one had ever done red in the hosiery
space before i want it to be bold
stand out i knew that if i got a chance
to be on the shelf
with no money to advertise it had to
jump out and say i'm new i'm different
try me
so i put three animated illustrated
cartoon women
on the package which had also never been
done before there had only ever been
photography
on these poetry packages i was working
on it every night
after work on my friend's computer she
had just finished
graphic design school so i would come
home and we would sit side by
side and i was cutting out lips and eyes
and i was very you know excited about
how to make it
design wise i wanted it to feel like you
were buying
a present for yourself instead of a
commodity that we dreaded
rule number six innovate with mark cuban
what is your thing and when did you kind
of
understand what it was it hasn't changed
my thing is
learning learning whatever is new and
applying it in ways that other people
aren't thinking of and so when i started
i got fired from a job selling software
started a company
and within six months this is the early
days of pcs i recognized that okay
we need to connect pcs together back
then you walked around you had your 500
quarter inch floppy and you know who
would need to connect to pc
we started you know writing software for
local area networks became a systems
integrator
30 some million dollar run rate and sold
it to h r block
and then got to the internet okay let's
look at this internet thing
someone's going to need to put audio and
then video on there great and then after
yahoo did yahoo
right i'm like you know what i'm looking
at these big screen tvs that cost thirty
thousand dollars
that are high definition television sets
and i'm thinking
you know what eventually they're gonna
follow the price performance curve
of traditional of traditional um
consumer electronics
and they're going to come down to price
so i started the first all high
definition tv network called hdnet
then i'm looking and saying okay you
know what it's like 2006 2007
and traditional television and cable is
going um digital
i'm saying you know what there's going
to be more a lot of storage space than
first access digital space
that cable companies aren't used to
using so let's take
a movie production company that we
created and
let's make it available for day and date
distribution where people can will pay
20 bucks um to the the cable company to
watch this brand new movie
and we get to keep 10 of it and so we
had 29 29 productions we started
producing movies
and lo and behold the first movie we
created was a documentary called enron
the smartest guys in the room
got nominated for academy award then we
didn't really create any good ones after
that but
by being first leveraging digital
storage we were able to take advantage
and make a lot of money
and in the mba with the mavericks you
know just doing those types of things
and it's what i like to do now
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is know that you are enough with jamie
kern lima
i kind of knew deep down inside like
okay i'm i'm created
for more in the sense of like i have
more to give and
and more to create um and more to serve
and more to see
and i always kind of knew it um and i
went through this
really life-long journey though of like
like
like knowing i i was kind of created for
more but doubting it
anyway and kind of my whole life
actually and maybe a lot of people out
there may be in the same
spot and it's kind of why i wrote the
book because i feel like
while it's my story of going from a girl
who didn't believe in herself
to like believing in herself and not not
trusting herself to learning actually
how to kind of like break through all
the self-doubt and hear
that inner voice and like and trust it
um
go from doubting i'm enough to really on
that journey of knowing i'm enough
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i think there definitely are
things that one can iterate on
but the the core thing is to have a
great
product and then you can always improve
and and iterate on that in all sorts of
ways and i think
you know i think um even in in the tech
industry um
uh what's striking is how um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were
it was just they had a great product and
then years later
they were able to optimize it in all
sorts of all sorts of ways um
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
um i think that uh that rarely works um
i think it's always
worth asking you know where you're gonna
go with this business um
and so i think we're always focused on
very short time horizons because
you have to figure out a way to get
through the next month the next quarter
you know how do you get some customers
how do you how do you track but it's
it's always worth thinking ahead
you know five to ten years you know why
will this be a really valuable business
in five to ten years
and um you know how's the competitive
landscape going to develop how's
technology going to develop how's the
world going to develop
um these are hard questions to answer
but i think um i think i think
i think the the great entrepreneurs that
i know always have some perspective
on it and it might be wrong but it's
just this is what's going to happen and
then it's sort of well reasoned and and
so you have a
you have a plan it and you know it's uh
when i when i was playing chess
uh you know in junior high school one of
the early lessons i learned was a bad
plan is still
always better than no plan at all right
and so you know
have a plan you can always change it but
don't don't just pretend that uh
that you have no clue about what's gonna
happen and that everything
about the future is random if you if you
sort of say that everything's random and
out of your control
that's that's that's the way you set
yourself up for failure the average
person who's listening too many people
think that they can go into this very
difficult zero-sum game
of betting against the consensus and be
right
you know what i mean in other words
investors says i'm gonna go in the
markets i'm gonna make money
betting against the consensus and be
right right because the consensus is
built into the price
okay okay that's what's up so it's think
of it as like going to a horse race
and there's handicaps okay you're not
going to pick the best horse
and you're not going to pick the best
company a terrible company can be a
better investment than a
uh a terrific company a terrible company
could be a better investment just like
the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are changing like you go into that and
that
becomes the long shot but because the
long shot
is going to pay off 25 to 1
right if he comes in that
um you could just as likely bet on the
long shot as the leader and it's going
to be equally likely that you're going
to make money right
otherwise you'd otherwise the market
would be doing the opposite
well the market is like that right in
other words if everybody believes that
something's going to be terrific
okay then everybody's betting on it and
it's price is high
so it's not what's best necessarily
it's what's best relative to what's in
the price what's discounting
what i learned going to beauty salon and
asking them after the news director had
told me that my hair was too thick and
my
eyes were too far apart and i needed a
makeover and um
sitting in a beauty salon in a french
beauty salon allowing them to put a
french perm on my black hair
and having the perm burn through my
cerebral cortex
and not being the woman that i am now so
not having the courage to say
this is burning me
and coming out a week later bald and
having to go on the air
you learn a lot about yourself when
you're black and a woman and bald and
trying to be an anchor woman
you learn you learn you're not diana
ross
and that you're not barbara walters
trying to be i was at the time
i had a lot of lessons i remember going
on the air many times and uh
not reading my copy ahead of time and uh
i was on the air one night and
ran across the word b-a-r-b-a-d-o-s um
that may be barbados to you but it was
barbados to me that night
and telling the story as an anchor woman
about a vote
in abstentia california i thought it was
located near san francisco
and one of the worst one of the worst
this is when i broke out of my barber
shell because i'm sitting there crossing
my legs trying to talk like barbara be
like barbara
and i was reading a story about someone
with a
blaze attitude which
if i had gone to wellesley i would have
known it was blase
and i started to laugh at myself on the
air and broke through my barbara shell
and had decided on that day that
laughing was okay even though barbara
hadn't
at that time
and it was through my series of mistakes
that i learned that i could be a better
oprah than i could be a better barber
and i allowed barbara to be the mentor
for me
as she always has been and i decided
then
to try to pursue the idea of being
myself and i am just thrilled that i get
paid so much every day for just
just being myself but it was a lesson
long in coming
recognizing that i had the instinct that
the inner voice
that told me that you need to try to
find a way
to answer to your own truth was the
voice i needed to be still and listen to
get this this is just remember this
because this will happen many times your
life
when people show you who they are
believe them the first time
not the 29th time
[Applause]
that's particularly good when it comes
to to men's situations
because when he doesn't call back the
first time
when you're mistreated the first time
when you see someone who shows you a
lack of integrity or dishonesty
the first time know that that will be
followed
by many many many other times that will
at some point in life come back to haunt
or hurt you
when people show you who they are
believe them
the first time live your life from a
point of view of truth and you will
live your life from truth and you will
survive
everything everything i believe even
death
you will survive everything if you can
live your life from a point of view of
truth people ask me why
e-commerce so successful in china
our company alone is much bigger than
amazon
why e-commerce in china one of the
reasons why e-commerce in china's
success successful because china had a
terrible infrastructure of commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have
so many like walmart camera everywhere
it's
it's just a terrible backward
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come
people love it so so efficient why china
mobile phone you know grow much faster
than america
america and europe have such a great
such a great system of telephone
we don't have 10 of them right amount
like 100 family can only have one
telephone that days
when mobile come we love that we just go
that
so there is a lip flop we don't have the
rules or laws
most of the government offices they
don't know how to make rules laws for
internet because nobody realizes what
the internet
look like so that leave us a chance to
grow fast
europe very interesting you have such a
perfect
rules or loss then everything they do
let's follow the rules or loss
and everything we think about the thing
they do let's follow the rules or loss
and everything we think about they start
to worry when they're worried they make
a rules loss
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules or laws you have
a problem
that can make rules a loss so
i worry about europe
i worry i worry about the worries of the
europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have the solutions for
artificial intelligence
oh you know they're going to destroy a
lot of things in human life
forget it let me tell you artificial
intelligence
i think we alibaba using artificial
intelligence to arrest and
catch a lot of thieves my theory i told
my engineers i said
now when you love somebody you may not
have reasons
but when you hate somebody you have
logic and reasons we have logic and
reasons
machine can always do better than that
so
we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
1 billion users using that there are so
many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch
all the thieves machine never forget no
matter how smart you are one person can
create
10 ways of cheating you are the smartest
person in the world
but we teach the machine every way
everything with this discover from other
people the machine can remember
over a hundred thousand ways of cheating
when you start the cheating
machine find you so
one way bad guys using artificial
intelligence
doing bad things other thing we're using
artificial intelligence
to catch bad guys so there is always
in any unbalance how you see the world
if you see technology revolution is a
problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started if you think
it's an opportunity the opportunity
just started the only thing is your
mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
by the way all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready everything's
perfect why they need you
because there is worries because there's
problems
because of there's no this know that
that is your opportunity
that is our opportunity and keep on that
you believing you can do something
little by little
10 years later you'll be different
that's that's that's
who we are this is the renaissance tower
in dallas and for a while it was the
tallest skyscraper in dallas
but the reason it's important to me is
that for many years this was the
headquarters of the blockbuster
corporation
and a certain meeting took place here in
the year 2000
that was actually very influential in
netflix's history
and in my evolution as an entrepreneur
now
in 2000 netflix was a pretty small
company we had less than a hundred
employees
probably had a few tens of thousands
subscribers
and we were on track to maybe do five
million dollars in revenue that year
but worse we were on track to lose 50
million dollars that year
now for those of you who can remember
the year 2000 that was not a good year
to be losing
50 million dollars so being sensible
entrepreneurs
we decided we had to pursue strategic
alternatives
which basically is code for how do we
get out of this
now the obvious candidate to look to was
blockbuster
now in 2000 blockbuster was on a very
different trajectory
blockbuster had six
billion dollars in revenue they had
six thousand stores they had ninety
thousand employees
so netflix was nothing to them and
despite our calls and our emails
we could not get them to even say a word
to us
until a few months later
we were on a corporate retreat and we
were in a little town called solvang
california
now we're pretty casual to begin with in
silicon valley and on retreat
even so much more so i think i had
packed
total one pair of flip-flops two pairs
of shorts
and some tank top t-shirts my partner
reed hastings
his gesture to dressing up was he had a
hawaiian shirt
and wouldn't you know it this is when
blockbuster calls and said
we will see you now so here we were in
solvang
and they wanted us in dallas the next
morning
so what do we do well we actually had a
lease a private jet
which to me was this unbelievable luxury
and a little bit of netflix trivia the
private jet was owned by vanna white
and we all piled on the jet we flew to
dallas and we got in the cab
went to the renaissance tower up to the
35th or 36th story got injured
put into a conference room which seemed
to me to be the size of this room
and i'm there of course in my shorts and
my flip-flops and my t-shirt
and reason is hawaiian shirt and then
come the blockbuster guys
and they have their fancy suits and are
thousand dollar
shoes and we sit down and we tell them
what you want to do we say
wouldn't it be great if you purchased us
and then we will run the online part of
the business
you guys can run the stores we have a
perfect synergy
and they nodded in all the right places
and they finally said
so how much do you think we should pay
for you so reed
screwed up all of his courage and he
said
50 million dollars you know what they
did
they laughed at us and the meeting went
downhill pretty quickly after that
and what i remember most though from
that day was flying home
on the jet it was very quiet
and all i could do was say to myself ugh
now we're gonna have to kick their ass
and you know it took us 10 years
[Music]
but eventually we drove blockbuster into
bankruptcy
now i tell you the story not to brag but
because
in some ways it's a very interesting
tale
on one hand it's inspiring that just a
handful of people
with a crazy idea and some persistence
could take down a six billion dollar
corporation
but the story's got a very different
meaning if you
are the six billion dollar corporation
because what it means is
you never know where your next threat's
coming from what it means is that
you have to disrupt yourself before
someone disrupts you for you
up till 2002 all we focused on was
survival
and then once we got public and and were
profitable we started thinking wow this
thing might last
and the the cruelest irony would be to
not want to work there
um you know to let it become a place we
didn't want to be and so we tried to
think through what do we really care
about
and realize what we really care about is
working with incredible people on hard
problems
and that that was the essence so we
should organize everything around
supporting that
of working with you know just incredibly
talented people and so that led us to
freedom and responsibility because
incredible people don't want to be
micromanaged
and the idea is that we manage through
setting context
and letting people run and you've got to
have the right people you've got to
reinforce that with values
setting context about what the company
is trying to achieve
but the idea is to build a system where
amazing amounts of
service improvement happen in the
marketing and the content
and the technology and the user
interface without direct intervention of
meat
and so some companies operate by you
know the product genius at the top and
we all know
these companies and this whole motif of
you know to be a great ceo you've got to
be the great product person who really
you know and it's intoxicating and fun
but you're building incredible amounts
of dependence on yourself
and eventually you know how well i know
how turkish consumers consume netflix
it's not that well and so you're much
stronger obviously building a
distributed
set of great thinkers people know that
but in the past what they've done
is try to make everything a process they
said okay i don't want it to be a genius
so we're going to organize a process for
everything
and these once in a while you heard
we're going to dummy proof it's going to
be such a good process that anybody this
was the ibm thing
and then if you dummy proof the process
you only get dummies to work there
you know to do the process and so that's
why
we're so you know opposed to that
instead so focused on giving people
great freedom realizing there'll be
mistakes
um but there'll be a lot of positive
achievement too can you
give some examples of that i mean you
know you talk about it generically it
sounds great but what are some specific
examples
i i take pride in making as few
decisions as possible as opposed to
as many as possible and so when
something significant changes in the
content or
the house of cards purchase you know ted
explained it it was a huge purchase at
that time
it was a half an hour conversation you
know we went back and forth i said are
you really sure it's a great bet yes
let's do it
you know it wasn't like me reading the
script and me meeting with kevin spacey
and you know
or equivalent samples on the marketing
more equivalent examples on
um the product and the evolution there
so it's creating a sense of
i want to make a difference and i can
make a difference and if that's what the
leader
gets excited about is that other people
are making a difference and you've got
the right people
you've got to be super demanding so the
you know one part is freedom and
responsibility
the other part is a high performance
culture where we say adequate
performance gets a generous severance
package
and so you know we look at it we say we
want to be like a major league baseball
team
and you know you've only got so many
positions on the field and if everyone
is not
incredible at what they do then you're
not going to win
so you turn over a lot of people and so
we turn over a lot of people we feel
like
you know we give people a fair shot and
you know we we hire pretty openly and
they know what they're getting into
but we're looking for people who for
whom freedom and responsibility works
because they do incredible work
this is how we keep our innovation
running i think usually
as companies get bigger they find it
really hard to have
small innovative projects and we had
this problem too for a while and we said
oh
we really need a new concept you know
the google ads that's a small project
that we're not quite sure if it's going
to work or not
but we hope it will and if we do enough
of them
some of them will really work and turn
out such as news but then we had a
we had a problem because then we had
over 100 projects
and i don't know about all of you but i
have trouble keeping 100 things in my
head at once
and we found that if we just wrote all
of them down
and ordered them and these are kind of
made up don't really pay attention to
them
for example the the by iceland which
from a media article we would never do
such a crazy thing but
in any case um we found if we just
basically wrote them all down and
ordered them
that uh most people would actually agree
what the ordering should be
and this was kind of a surprise to me
but we found that as long as you keep
the hundred things in your head
which you did by writing them down that
you could do a pretty good job deciding
what to do
and where to put your resources and so
that's basically what we've done
since we instituted that a few years ago
and i think it's really allowed us to be
innovative
and still stay reasonably well organized
throughout my 20s
i continued experimenting trying
different things
racing bikes and boats and constantly
changing jobs
it didn't take me long to discover that
the most interesting and rewarding
programming jobs
were found at a cluster of companies
located south of stanford university in
north of san jose
silicon valley was in its infancy
i was still in my twenties when i went
to work for my first
silicon valley startup amdahl
where we developed the world's fastest
mainframe computer
faster than anything ibm had next stop
was ampex
where we built the world's largest
digital data storage system
then on to precision instruments where
we built an even larger data storage
system
this time using lasers i was the vice
president in charge of software
development
it was all very cutting edge and
challenging and cool
i liked my work most of the time but i
didn't love it
i searched and i searched but i just
could not find a software engineering
job
that i loved as much as i loved sailing
so i tried to create one i put together
a plan to start my own company
that way i could completely control my
work environment
i would hire the most talented
programmers i knew
and we would all work together on the
most
interesting and challenging software
my projects my goal was to create the
perfect job
for me a job i truly loved
i never ex i never expected the company
to grow beyond 50 people
i think i asked you a question a general
question for all businesses if you were
coaching a business class or a company
how does a company remain nimble today
what does he have to do
my problem with most strategy
conversations is that they're always
inward out you know we establish well
first we're the best in the world
because everybody thinks that which
can't possibly be true
and second we see that all of our
products are going to be successful and
therefore we'll be very successful in
the future and that's usually how
strategy is done
in businesses i prefer a completely
different approach
work very very very hard to figure out
what the world's going to look like in
five years
what will people be doing what will your
customers want where will costs be
will be in our case what will networks
look like how important will phones be
what will the apps look like
what services and spend an awful lot of
time on that and then take a look at
your offerings
what are the strongest ones which are
the ones that are going to iterate
quickly
you're probably going to do fine there
you understand those businesses what
about these
others if you think about in the media
business there are business media
businesses that are going very well and
others that are in great trouble
this is completely predicted five years
ago right so
the leaders and the ones that are in
trouble should have
right done a five year plan and said
holy cow
what are we gonna do what are the things
we do or maybe we sell ourselves or we
try something different
but almost all of these strategic shifts
are predictable using my
my five year model almost nobody does a
five-year plan
most businesses do a one-to-two-year
plan
especially in our space but even in most
businesses the only business that i
discovered
that does a five-year or longer plan is
the oil and gas industry and the reason
is because they have to deploy so much
capital and do all this planning
but even there they have trouble because
the prices go up and down and so forth
so even there it's difficult
the way that we operate as a company
you know especially in dangote is like
what i said
we have a vision that vision will have a
strategy of how we are going to achieve
the
vision which we do normally over a
period of
five years you know i mean like today uh
we know where we are going even this
investment that i announced or 400
million dollars
here i didn't just sit down on my own
and just
say it it is part of our strategic plan
to invest in kenya time how many people
in the room would say they're
too busy not busy enough
that's a politically unpopular place to
put your hand but god bless you for
putting your hand up over there
the truth of the matter is thinking
about time
as something to be managed whether it's
how long for those of you or seniors i'm
sure you'll ask a question
how long will i do my first job how long
will i stay in my job
six months a year five years
how long before i decide whether i
really like my career how long
before i really like my major how am i
really managing my time
i got involved a lot of extracurriculars
the one that broke the bank for me
was becoming publisher of the advocate
i'm not even sure why i did it
really i'm not sure why i did it was
another resume build
i was already busy with football in the
crimson
but i but i did it and then time
management
really got into my vocabulary i really
did have to manage
and i don't even measure i started
skipping class i already sort of
confessed to that
but managing time even amongst the
extracurriculars
got to be a a big big deal today i
actually keep a spreadsheet
a budget these are all the things i'm
going to do in my life here's how much
time is budgeted to them and allocated
i record everything into my into outlook
i have a macro that spits it out in
excel and i do budget versus actual
comparisons
now it's a little different since i've
quote retired unquote
uh but at microsoft i could tell you i
was going to have 12 one-on-ones with
harry this year and then i would track
them how many did i have
i was going to spend 10 hours a year
talking to customers over the telephone
versus in person and i i just measure
everything because i think time is so so
important
i was interested um as a sort of
young young 14 15 year old
about and what was going on around the
world and
um and i was inquisitive um
and uh and the vietnamese war
uh was raging and um
it seemed to me as it seemed to a lot of
young people a very
unjust war as most wars
actually turn out to be and um
and i like a lot of other people wanted
a campaign to try to
stop it and
there was no uh young person's magazine
at the time
um and um and it's quite strange because
i'm dyslexic
that i should feel that i can
uh who's dyslexic in this room
all all the best people in the world are
just like sorry with the rest of you but
anyway
um they um uh but um
yeah so being dyslexic thinking that i
could be an editor of a magazine but
um but anyway i thought i could give it
a shot
and but and and so i decided to leave
school
and start a magazine to uh
yeah a campaigning magazine to try to
reform education
and try to tackle issues like like
things like the vietnamese war and the
biafran war and other wars that were
going on at the time
um i never thought i i was becoming an
entrepreneur i don't think the word
entrepreneur actually existed 50 years
ago and
in britain all the all businesses were
run by
governments really british gas british
coal british telecom british airways you
know
and so the word entrepreneur didn't
really exist
but in starting this magazine
i had to make sure it survived i didn't
have any money so
so i had to worry about printing and
paper manufacturing and distribution and
selling it and
uh and that started taking up quite a
lot of time
and uh and the word survival was very
important because
in those days you couldn't uh raise
money to start your businesses you had
to sort of
try to start the fund them just fund
them from people wanting to buy
advertising or
or buying copies of your magazine and um
so i learned i learned the art of being
an entrepreneur
uh by you know in the jungle trying
trying to survive
and the magazine became my education and
uh and it was a you know a lot of fun
and um
and one thing one thing led on to
another you don't realize
i am so frustrated
like i am so frustrated like i am so
i've got
so much i want to give i've got ideas on
color palettes i've got ideas on
silhouettes and i've got a million
people telling me why i can't do it
you know that i'm not a real designer
i'm not this i'm not a real rapper
either
i'm not a real musician either like i
don't know how to play the piano
like i'm an artist i went to art college
i went to art college
and was looked at like i'm soft because
i like wore like italian clothes you
know what i'm saying when i'm rapping in
front of camera
and my pants is tight trying to spit a
verse for care
you know so that's the same when i'm
sitting there you know
like sitting there at a fashion show
like i'm there because i appreciate
phoebe follow i appreciate raph simmons
i appreciate
ricardo tishi and i look at them as my
peers as creative people who dedicate
their entire life
to making something better for the world
is that let me explain what anybody
that knows an artist and you know
someone that's giving that if you know
artists there's only one thing you can
say give or ask them when you see them
there are two words thank you
there's no why didn't you do this yo i
want that what's the
no we dedicate our entire life
to making our current time and
civilization
better to adding something to the
culture
and there is only two words that you can
say
thank you what would you like to see as
your legacy what is it that you would
like to say
that you achieved with your life well i
think i want my kids to look back and
say
he was a great mayor and honest and made
a big difference in the city but i think
the things that will
last are things like the life expectancy
um numbers or the economic development
of new york city compared to
other cities or reforming education
which is always a two step forward one
step back thing
but if we can be an impetus to rahm
emanuel for example
to stand up and fight for control of the
school system
in chicago or elsewhere around the
country
i think those would be good legacies if
we could figure out a ways to stop this
carnage from
illegal guns that would be another thing
but if you go back
go down the road and look back those the
kinds of things
investment in uh educational
institutions uh
my alma mater johns hopkins that you're
on the board of or
harvard where my one of my daughters
went to graduate school and i did
or princeton or nyu those universities
will i hope
make a difference in the world and i'll
be a little bit a little part of it
um at hopkins we have a malaria project
for example
trying to build a better mosquito and
the reason you you want a mosquito
that's tougher than the others that
uh doesn't carry the malaria parasite
and then it would drive out the others
it's really probably the only ways
to stop malaria which kills a couple
million people every year
when uh our nobel prize winner who runs
the
uh project wins his second nobel prize
and i've challenged him to do so
i'll have a little bit of that prize
because i helped fund it and so will the
clinicians and other scientists that
work with them and so will
patients that work with us we don't do
anything on our own
and everybody collaborates and gets
something from somebody else
and i also hope that i will set a
standard and that
whoever comes after me will be a better
mayor than i am
i'm going to live in new york city and i
i'm always in my
life tried to hire people smarter than
me i've certainly done that with
my deputy mayors in the city i've
certainly done that with the people that
are running bloomberg
and hopefully the public will pick a
successor
that will turn out to be nobody will
ever think anybody is at the beginning
but always you know
will turn out to be a better mayor and
we'll take it forward and i hope that
washington gets its act together and
starts understanding
uh we are in trouble in this country and
now ferguson wrote a great story about
the end of civilizations and how quickly
things can collapse rome and in couple
decades the ussr
in a couple of years i mean it was the
second biggest power in the world in two
years it's gone
we really are on a cliff
and it's not just the fiscal cliff we're
going we're already over the fiscal
cliff the question is are we going to
pull a rip cord or just keep falling
but we're on a cliff socially as well
and the world is not necessarily on our
side i think
young people uh you know in some ways
their
their life is much easier than you know
sort of my life might have been
at that stage just you know for i think
all of us
uh you know having before
whatever if we're traveling to
switzerland it'd be a big stressful
thing how do you get in touch with
people before mobile phones arrange your
travel
figure out how to exchange your currency
you know
there are many things you know we can
whip our phones out and look up anything
and figure out how to get somewhere
there are a lot of affordances that are
such conveniences today that make it
easy
but there is also a global stage that
makes it hard
actually uh you know because
if uh when i was in school
and i was on the math team or whatever
it was just compared to other kids in
the school and i
did quite well against them you know and
i found myself yeah i'm good at that i'm
good at that
uh i think i find younger folks today
are
their measures of themselves are always
especially you know the ambitious ones
are on this global stage i said like
well
you know i have to be you know number
one in the world at this or
that and i'm like you know that's a
really tall order
um and i think it can be discouraging in
a way
because if you know you know those folks
say well you know i'm number one
thousand
in the world at this game which which
you know in my world would have been an
enormous achievement
because that means like you were
definitely the best in like your city
and your state and whatnot but
um but it's it's hard and i think you
know they get
there's a little bit of discouragement
so uh you know i would encourage young
folks to you know take
chances and pursue their dreams
and uh you know try to silence out kind
of the voices that say well
actually there are like a thousand
startups trying to do whatever
self-riding bicycles or whatever it is
they happen to be doing
one nice things the key is to have fun
in your startup and not
from the beginning on to think of the
ipo which may bring you a billion
um that's keep and that was certainly
not your motivation to make it a success
yeah i mean i i certainly had no dreams
of such economic success
and uh i think you're exactly right i
think you should have
uh fun and not be so weighed down
by the weight of expectations
that i think sort of this global network
unfortunately one of the downsides i
think it creates that way
what are the things you think about that
make companies successful in this type
of environment
versus those that struggle well i think
it starts with us having
a long-term view rather than a
short-term view
and always thinking of how we can be
successful long-term by creating value
with for others starting with our
customers
and employees and so
when we look at it that way there's
always
uncertainty so it starts with being
prepared with that
and and recognizing that the future
is unknown and unknowable so the way we
have
prepared ourselves for that is focusing
on building capabilities that will be
make us successful under a whole variety
of conditions which means
having more flexibility more optionality
more diversity and so those are the
things
that we've always tried to do and so the
starting point
is is building capabilities that will
enable us to create value with others
starting with our customers
and then finding the opportunities
or the sets of customers for whom we can
create the most value
and then as we do not resting on our
laws but
recognizing the future is going to be
different than the past
then continually improving and adding to
those capabilities
and as we do then we see oh with those
capabilities
we can now pursue additional
opportunities
and then as we start pursuing those
opportunities we realize well we need
additional capabilities so we add still
more capabilities
so this creates what i've called a
virtuous cycle of mutual benefit
where it's continual improvement
and growth and and diversity which is
is a way in or or is
the way to deal with schumpeter's
what he called creative destruction my
father
started reliance with a hundred dollars
right when i joined reliance in 1980
the market value of reliance was
30 or 40 million dollars and
in 30 years the opportunities that were
provided
by this country has enabled us
to create wealth for india
my father was a big believer that
any business that has the
sole purpose of making money is not
worth doing
right business must serve
a larger societal purpose reliance
raised all its money from
capital markets and from individual
small shareholders so we've created a
million millionaires
just by investing in reliance out of
ordinary indians
and that is the process of creating
wealth for the country once
you create opportunity wealth comes
the group of people that do not use
quality in their marketing
are the japanese you never see them
using quality in their marketing
it's only the american companies that do
and yet if you ask people on the street
which products
have the best reputation for quality
they will tell you the japanese products
now why is that how could that be the
answer is because
customers don't form their opinions on
quality from marketing
they don't form their opinions on
quality from who won
the the deming award or who won the
baldrige award
they form their opinions on quality from
their own experience with the products
or the services
and so one can spend enormous amounts of
money on quality one can win every
quality award there is and yet if your
products
don't live up to it customers will not
keep that opinion for long in their
minds and
so i think where we have to start is
with our products and our services
not with our marketing department and we
need to get back to the basics
and go improve our products and services
now again
quality isn't just the product or the
service it's having
the right product you know knowing where
the market's going and having the most
innovative products
is just as much a part of quality as the
quality of the construction of the
product when you have it
[Music]
if you want even more insights into how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there we don't love
this product but we think
others will love it you know that's not
really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time
is such a key component of your life